for me it was just that all the ladies
in my high school were into that
d'angelo video
if you didn't look like that they
weren't into you so i was like i don't
know how many crunches it's gonna take
me
hello everyone and welcome to the roast
of your teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
got a five on my ap us history exam
elise morales and with us today we have
the very funny and talented comedian
actor
voice actor and writer former douglas
mckay high school student ron funchess
the royal scots okay
so you guys i that was literally going
gonna be my first question is what was
your mascot it's the royal scots
yeah the guy in a kilt playing a bagpipe
which to me
if he had to fight a bear or a lion or
anything of that nature he
obviously is gonna lose i mean just have
a shield
and a sword but you know you don't want
to fight a lion with just that and then
also
you know you get your junk easily that's
exactly what i was gonna say like but
maybe
was it that he was like a larger than
life
scottish man
i mean by our sports teams you know he
was just a regular guy he wasn't doing
anything special because we lost most of
our games we were
we were by far the worst high school in
the city when it came to sports so
so we do we have a picture of him up
right now and he does have like
i mean i would say fashion wise he's oh
he's great yeah
he's got a gorgeous green ensemble like
the hat
giant yellow m m which is cool
which if you're fighting a bear maybe he
throws the eminem the bear goes for the
eminem
i'm not gonna let eminem that big go to
anybody not even
there okay so what was your relationship
to your high school at the time were you
like school spirit or were you like
[ __ ] this place um i was a floater you
know i think that's
is i'm the same now as i was then i had
a lot of acquaintances but not very many
friends
you know i moved around a lot i grew up
in chicago illinois
but i went to high school in salem
oregon which was a lot different a lot
different culture wise i came from a
place a lot of hip-hop and a lot of
black people and i went to a place a lot
of country music and no black people
yeah that sounds like an adjustment it
was quite a adjustment but i think
overall it helped me
in my life because it it helped me get
rid of a lot of prejudices that i had
against white people or um and just
learn to see people as people and
[ __ ] as
[ __ ] you know and i think that's
helped me now where i'm just
same thing just floater going around i
have a lot of acquaintances and just a
handful of friends
so what year did you make that move from
chicago to oregon
i don't know years
[Laughter]
like what what age about was it like
13 13 years old okay because i so
i moved from los angeles to virginia
when i was
12. and i remember like when i was doing
that move
i tried to have like a strategy going in
like i had like a new friend's strategy
um and i was gonna my my strategy was to
lean heavily on that i was from
california and just see how far that
could take me
but did you do you remember if you had
like
a new school strategy when you moved or
were you just like
gonna feel like like i i don't know
these people i don't really like it here
i miss my mom i was living with my dad
and stuff at the time and so i was just
kind of like i hate it here
um but for my thing was just that i was
a black guy from chicago
so for the first week i was very popular
like all the
coaches would come up to me and be like
hey we want you to come try out for
football
come try out for basketball you know the
girls were talking to me and then they
found out it just took a week for them
to realize that i was a nerd with no
athletic talent
and uh once that happened they just kind
of let me go
uh that is in many ways the exact
experience i had with my california
strategy like once they realized that i
was actually not like
i couldn't surf like i didn't have any
cool
like attributes they were done with me
it was over
yeah kids are fickle kids are fickle but
i
i loved i mean no i didn't love it i'd
say i loved it
oh my god tell me about that oh my god
i mean it was a formative time is nice
to go
back now and be like oh there wasn't
that much pressure i put the most
pressure on myself you know
but i think when you're a teenager
through
your mid-20s everything is kind of more
dramatic
everything is more um important because
it's new it's the first time you've ever
experienced these things first time you
experience love the first time you
experience heartbreak
and they're all so much more dramatic
than they become later in your life
you know so do you remember like
what was causing you the most anxiety at
that time was it usually like
friend related drama was it usually
relationship
drama like oh it's family drama mostly
is that i'd gone from living with my mom
and she was in an abusive relationship
and so i left to go live with my dad in
oregon
found out he was in an abusive
relationship with a lady that he had met
in narcotics anonymous which is
not a place you're supposed to pick up
women
so did that play out in your
like all this stuff that was going on at
home did that play out in your school
life were you like
causing trouble to get some of that
energy out or were you did you have like
an extracurricular you put a lot of your
time into
no i was a real slacker for the most
like until 16 i was just kind of a nerd
and i would um
read a lot i was i was uh sitting in
front of my locker ignoring people
reading moyer
and reading jd salinger just reading
just escaping whatever
existentialism or whatever type of book
that i could get there was like okay
this is what i'm into that's what really
changed my high school around was that
um after they found out i wasn't in
sports and they weren't really paying
attention to me i kind of was just doing
regular classes and then
it took my junior year where they were
doing some testing and they were like oh
you should be in some of these
advanced placement classes and once they
put me in those that you know it's a lot
more challenged i had a lot more fun and
that's kind of what
kept me going through that was that ap
english class that was the only time i
was like oh i can write a you let me
write an essay about outcast
cool so do you do you remember like
the the first assignment that you got
where you were like oh
finally someone's like speaking to me on
my level yeah
that'd be that one when we had to yeah
we had to just basically plan a poem
that meant something to us and break and
analyze it break it down
and so i picked a song called
synthesizer off of the outcast
um an outcast album i don't remember
which album thinks of with women
uh but it meant a lot to me this is a
guy named george clinton who i
loved that was a part of it and so um
that was the first time
where and he was the teacher was also
taking us out to like plays
and i was taking trips to portland from
salem and
that kind of like opened my eyes like oh
there's a bigger city here there's more
culture here there's more diversity here
and that that really helped me
oh so once you like once you got into ap
at your school you got to do like
special activities and stuff too
and like go and see stuff outside your
world that's cool
yeah yeah that was really what was
helpful for me because
i've just never been a fan i couldn't do
busy work that's what
i applaud my son for like my son
actually just turned 17
today so it's um really weird to see
like when i was doing this and thinking
about the differences between him and i
at those ages because you know when i
was 17 at that point i was a big stoner
trying to like find girls just trying to
do stuff and my son's so
into his homework and so into just like
he's
he's like oh i'm glad i'm 17 i can start
watching r rated movies
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast is brought
to you by purple purple is improving the
way we sleep with their patented
technology the purple grid it's the only
comfort innovation
that provides total pressure relief
absolute airflow
and ergonomic support that's because the
grid's open air channels adapt to
your natural shape natural shape
natural shape that's hard to say listen
the grid's open
air channels adapt to your natural shape
while neutralizing body heat
so you stay comfortably cool all night
yes here we are
once again it's the ad where i remind
you all that i'm a sweaty sleeper
but not with purple because the purple
grid is the only comfort technology that
instantly adapts to your body and sleep
style and its open air channels and
temperature
neutral composition eliminate pressure
and keep you
cool all at once so no more sweaty
sleeping for me every purple product
ships free and is delivered
right to your door so if you're not
completely satisfied you can return your
product
for a full refund and purple is so
confident
so confident in what they do every
product comes with a risk free trial
purple has financing available as low as
zero percent apr for qualified customers
and monthly payments are easy on your
budget and there are no
hidden fees get the mattress what
are you waiting for listen experience
the purple grid and you'll sleep like
never before go to purple.com teen
self 10 and use promo code teen
self 10 for a limited time and you'll
get
10 off your order of 200 or more
that's purple.com teen self
10. promo code teen self 10
that's t e e t-e-e-n-s-e-l-f the number
one the number zero
for ten percent off any order of two
hundred percent or more
terms apply how do you keep your mind
sharp if trivia is what keeps you on
your toes
you need to play trivia star it's the
best way to test yourself see
what random pieces of knowledge you
remember from high school
trivia star is a free mobile quiz game
that's entertaining and
challenging and you can choose
categories like music sports movies tv
animals celebrities
and over 60 others to choose from so
there's always
more trivia to explore if you choose the
correct answer from multiple choices and
beat the clock
you move on to the next level it's
pretty much a standard
trivia game but the questions get harder
over time
so if you get stuck i'm gonna take that
line again whoever's editing this
but the questions get harder over time
so don't worry
if you get stuck you can use coins and
gems to get a hint and beat the level
and trivia star has two
thousand five star reviews in the apple
store join them today
to see if you are smart enough to win
right now trivia star is offering you
2 500 coins and 500 gems when you
download and play
just go to apple or google store and
search for trivia star
again search trivia star and enjoy 2 500
coins
and 500 gems download trivia star for
free
today if you're still using one of the
big wireless providers this year
have you asked yourself what you're
paying for
between expensive retail stores inflated
prices and hidden fees
you are being taken advantage of because
they know
you'll pay enter mint mobile mint
mobile provides the same premium network
coverage you're used to
but at a fraction of the cost because
everything is online
mint mobile saves on retail locations
and overhead then passes those savings
directly onto you mint mobile makes it
easy to cut your wireless bill down to
just
15 bucks a month
every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide and text and
talk with mint mobile stop paying for
unlimited data you'll never use
choose between plans with three eight or
12 gigabytes of 4g lte data i assure you
it's enough i promise you don't even
want to be using your phone that much we
all want to be outside we want to be
president come on
use your phone with any mint mobile plan
and keep your same
phone number along with all of your
existing contacts
ditch your old wireless bill and start
saving with mint
mobile to get your real wireless plan
for just 15 bucks
a month and get a plan shipped to your
door for free
go to mintmobile.com teen self
that's mint mobile.com team self
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
teen self
do you have like a a role model that you
were kind of trying to
like style yourself out after like uh if
only everyone at my high school thought
i was
like this person then i'd have it made
mine was avril lavigne
oh i could see that for you i could see
that for you then
yeah i remember i brought in a picture
of her when i was like 15 to get my hair
cut and it was like when she had like
the thin
blonde like like hair that was like dip
dyed on the bottom
and i brought a picture of her into the
hair salon and i was like please make my
hair look like this
and my hair stylist had to be like
you are hispanic that
is never happening for you
for me it was just that all the ladies
in my high school were into that
d'angelo video where he
was you know he was shirtless up to the
up to the crotch tool area
as we could see the top of the crotch
you know everybody was into that video
and
so back then so like if you didn't look
like that they weren't into you so i was
like i don't know how many crunches it's
going to take me
how did you stack up against the
d'angelo video
oh well not well at all it didn't go
well it's probably why i didn't have sex
until i was 18.
[Laughter]
with that a high school 18 or out of
high school 18. high school 18.
but then um you know that lady became my
wife and
i'm the mother of my child oh my god
is it a little bit longer so
now i feel like i've like buried the
lead on my podcast about high school so
you are married to your
high school sweetheart or a high school
sweetheart i was
not anymore yes no
well you were married to your high
school
sweetheart was that like your one
relationship
of high school or did you have other
ones before that or was it like
you were a high school couple um that
was it i didn't really talk to
girls i was really shy i was very shy
person and and i
always just kind of had this um fear in
me of like oh i have to
you know they'll probably say no so i
better you know i gotta make sure i make
sure and you know by the time i was done
making sure they moved on you know
so um she was my first girlfriend and
first when i was 18 and we knew each
other from we had a screen printing
class together
and we just you know made fun of each
other and and hit it off and
she became yeah i went to prom together
at 18
and then had my son with her when i was
20 and then we got divorced when i was
30.
um i feel like those early like the art
classes in particular were such
fertile ground for flirting and like
finding someone because there you always
were able to like
pair up and there was like a good amount
of down time in those classes to like
mess around and actually talk
yeah that's all it was if you want to go
home back if you want to go screen print
and you want to go
art is really just like who in here is
open to [ __ ] who would hear
uh parents haven't gotten them down to
not [ __ ] well at my school there was
also a photography class and the
photography kids got access to the dark
room
and i like i never took photography but
i
i truly couldn't imagine a more like
sexually charged environment than a dark
room at that time
yeah i would imagine just being like let
me take a photo of you and then
let's develop it together and then the
next thing you know
you know you're pregnant yes
i remember one time me and my friends
like we just went
in there we didn't even do anything we
caused zero trouble
i think literally my friend developed a
photo like did what the room was
for and i felt like i was committing a
crime the entire time
yeah dark rooms are sexy it's a shame
they're gone
but there's that's a sexy room it's just
all like just things hanging up on
clothespins and red lights
come on yeah it's a it's a truly sensual
environment um
do you remember any big like scandals
of your high school like a thing that
everybody was talking about
yeah of course multiple scandals i mean
you know there's always
like old ladies who got pregnant senior
year that's always the thing and then
you're like oh my god i'm so happy
because i wanted to go out with them
because i knew that
that i could possibly have sex but now
i'm glad that they turned me down
um but the biggest one in my entire high
school involved
my principal my principal was kind of
nationally renowned because he came up
with this program
um that was basically the snitching
program where you would tell on your
fellow students if
they had like drugs or they were
fighting or whatever if they're doing
anything and then they would give you
money for snitching on your fellow
student
and so school would give you money
do you remember how much money it's like
50 bucks
as a teenager though that's so much
oh it turned there it turned it into a
hell hole you know and you couldn't
trust nobody
because everybody was gonna snitch each
other some people would plant stuff on
each other you know
it's crazy like that yeah well teenagers
are
also like they're petty and they don't
know consequences
really so it's like you get an idea in
your head and you're like haha
like i could see teenagers being like
haha wouldn't it be funny
if i told him my friend and got 50 and
then it's like your friend is now
expelled from school
yeah it was like the second season of
orange is the new black before it got
like really deep into the stuff but
still you know
fun some fun things were happening um
so so he did that so he was on like 2020
he was on like a lot of different shows
and he got a big head and he was all
excited he's walking around like the
[ __ ] of the walk you know
and then right before i graduated it was
found out
that he was sexually harassing several
teachers
possibly students and in faculty
of the of the school using his being a
principal to
intimidate people into having sex with
him and so then he got
fired and then they put the whole thing
out about that
and he disappeared but then guess what
guess what
i just thought about this a month ago so
i went to tell my friend because he's
from my same town
and so we went to look it up and then we
found a story
from 2018 where he had where he went and
found a small
town in oregon to go be a principal of
and then
he then someone whistle blew on him and
then they had to kick him out of that
school
oh my god
that that is so crazy and i love that
ultimately what brought him down was
like someone snitched on him
yes like you you put all this snitching
out in the world and then you get
snitched on sir
absolutely he deserves it
so do you like so this all went down or
at least the first
part of this went down while you were
still at the school
do you remember like the day the news
broke
at school or yeah we were pretty happy
as students
because we didn't like him because you
know he because he
made this program that turned students
against each other
and then once he got some fame from
being on tv
he you could see it he'd walk around
with his chest all
puffed out you know he would just talk
me and the students talked me into the
teachers apparently
and so when we found out we were like
yeah [ __ ] you you deserve this
that is so wild so did they have to
did they just get you a new principle in
the middle of the year or did like the
vice versa
from principal nice lady yeah she was
great
um yeah he just disappeared but you know
they didn't really tell us we had to go
and find out later
of why he was gone you know so they
didn't like
they didn't address it as a school at
all
no they were just like he's gone
[Laughter]
what who what what principle we don't
this has always been the principle you
guys are acting like you loved him just
10 minutes ago
my high school had a scandal with our
principal to a much lesser degree
but basically our principal was this
very aloof
man and so they wanted to do like a
retro
they wanted to do like a thing on his
life in the oakton outlook which was our
newspaper so that everyone would like
get to know the principal and
what his life was about and in the the
whole spread the day that it came out
was that
i guess he's like a big game hunter and
the main picture that they chose of him
was him
holding a dead cougar that he had shot
and our mascot was the oakton cougars
and so it was
like this insane article that came out
of him holding
our dead mascot and the students didn't
like it
i wouldn't imagine plus it seems like
you like
going hunting cougars doesn't seem like
a fun thing that
no need at all no i don't think that
that should be happening and all of us
were just kind of like what the hell
like uh and then a facebook group sprang
up making fun of him and
it was a whole thing that sounds fun
that sounds a little
less seedy i like that one yeah what it
was and me and my friends all wrote in
the facebook group and we were like they
should stuff the cougar and put it in
the front hall
and we would you know we thought that
was really funny and so
ultimately we turned it into something
really positive
what's good teens do did you know you
wanted to do comedy or performing or
acting or any of that at that time was
that on your radar or were you
on a completely different wavelength i
mean comedy has always been on my radar
but
not at that point it definitely was not
something i thought was a real job
you know i i i knew i had an interest in
comedy and working in comedy products
since i was five
years old but i didn't i was like you
know this is just the thing you're born
famous you're born a comedian you know
i didn't know that about open mics or
things like that but
um the thing that when i go back in my
high school and i look back at it and
see that it did kind of prep me for
being
a comedian is the fact that i did win
um funniest person in my school and
it was called class clown or clown i got
a
rubber duck i got all that but i was
never a class pile like i was never like
the traditional class clown i was i
wasn't the guy like oh
let's make fun of a teacher or like get
up and throw something like that you
know
i was the guy who would see the class
clown
and then i would tap my friend on the
shoulder and make fun of the class clown
and then i guess i did that to enough
people that they were like
actually you're the funniest one
well that's a huge accomplishment to be
able to get class clown without like
the whoopee cushions the fake nose
all the stuff that you need to do i
remember kidding and i was just like i
was just
talking [ __ ] i was just saying how i
feel
like i wasn't joking were you surprised
because i
not to to my own horn but i also got a
superlative i was voted headed for
hollywood
which just meant like they knew i did
the plays
but um i remember being really surprised
and being like shocked that other people
would think of me
to write my name down yeah i remember
being shocked when i got my diploma and
there was like this
big cheer and i swear to god at that
moment that was the moment where i go
oh i'm not like a loser
[Laughter]
i thought the whole my whole high school
career i thought i was unpopular i
thought nobody really liked me
especially since i wasn't dating any
girls at all i thought no one liked me
and then when they heard my name and i
heard this like
pop like this cheer like you get when
we're on stage and i was like
oh no they actually they like me i wish
i had known that four years ago yeah
imagine the power if you had realized at
the time
does your high school acknowledge you at
all now
like have they asked you to come back
are you on their notable alumni
anything like that i don't know i don't
know i don't know if they know how to
reach me
[Laughter]
um i do know i went to phoenix recently
and i
saw a guy wearing a mckay jacket
and he came up to me and he had a couple
of things for me to sign and he was like
he's like i want you to sign these
things he's like i went to mckay he's
like i went you know
he went like five seven years after me
but he was like you're the most
famous person that went to mckay and i
was just like oh
cool yeah i was like are you the most
notable alumni would you would you one
of the most notable people in all of
salem oregon
are three we have three famous people
one of which is probably i mean i would
say
you know objectively still more famous
than me um napoleon dynamite is from
my town um there's a and one basketball
player
named the professor he was when they
when
i don't know if you're familiar with the
and one basketball
okay well there's regular basketball and
then they made this whole thing called
and one was just street ball people
doing tricks and there
was a white guy who was very tiny and
then grayson
grayson and he they called him the
professor and so for a long time he was
the most famous person from where i was
from
and now it's me wow i
from where i'm from
the most famous people from my high
school are the couple
they're called the they were the
salahi's and they broke into a white
house
dinner
[Laughter]
under obama they crashed a white house
dinner with the prime minister of india
and they both went to my high school and
were high school sweethearts at my high
school
they also they sound kind of like jerks
though yeah i mean it was it definitely
was not cool
crashing white house dinners that sound
you guess that's how people die
i think also obama was like new in
office and it like
it was like it made him look bad they
were like you're not even paying
attention to who's coming to the dinners
so it was it was not cool what they did
i hope to someday overtake them you will
thank you um okay we're we're nearing
we're coming up on the end here but i do
i do like to ask one final question
which is um if you could talk to your
high school self and give them any piece
of advice
any piece of wisdom what would you say
to your
high school self it doesn't matter that
none of this
matters it's all a temporary part of
your life to enjoy
this part of your life because these are
some fun friendships that you can make
and enjoy
and learn a lot from but overall that
none of this is as serious as you make
it out to be that you
hope that you're gonna have a long and
fruitful life and so that this is just
the beginning
of it and never let um
a four year period of any type whether
it be high school college
prison whatever you're going through
never let that define
who you are because you know during that
time period i had no idea that i would
end up
here end up in um tv
and stuff like i was talking to my
fiance now where it's just like
um during that time period after i had
my son my early 20s and stuff i was very
poor and i remember
doing coffee house shows in
in my hometown to just passing a hat
around trying to get enough money so
that i could bring my son home a happy
meal you know just to make sure that i
had
something to show when i came back home
and then now
because of the movie i'm a happy meal
toy
that's so crazy that's beautiful that's
your version of
uh that's a your positive version
of your snitching principle getting
sniffed
ultimately and if you had to like
i know it's honestly it's hard to say
but if you had to say like
would you say that you enjoyed your high
school experience
or could you take it or leave it
um i think i didn't enjoy it no i did
not enjoy it
but i would say that you don't have to
enjoy all your experiences and you still
learn from them and get a lot from them
um i learned a lot about myself i
learned a lot about
you learned a lot about culture you
learned a lot about how
um how to be an individual
while living in a group think situation
you know and that's something that we
have to do
in all of society but i think in high
school that's when it's at its most
that's when
you kind of look to your left look to
your right before you laugh at something
before you decide something is cool
before you decide if
if it's something that you were really
interested in and
i think because i moved around a bunch
because it was such a different high
school from where i came from
it let me know very quickly that i could
just like whatever i want
that i could be myself and that i that
that there's a power and a value to that
and i think that's helped my
comedy and helped my career immensely
yeah that's
that's so amazing and i i really agree
with this kind of idea that going back
to what you were saying before about
like you don't need to take the it as
seriously
i remember my high school self just i
felt like my high school was the entire
world and it has this way of like making
you feel like
all of these people are people you're
stuck with forever like the way your
life is now it's going to be like this
forever and it's so
that's also the one thing that i would
probably say to myself is like
there's so much left to happen this is
such a small
blip of your life yeah they're just
they're just
ships passing by you know and hopefully
you you hold on to a
couple of them but to be honest if
you're friends with everybody from your
high school you probably [ __ ] losers
so
like you know it's like if that's where
you peak that's
that's not a good place to pick so to me
if if you're in high school now
if you're like i'm hating it i'm not
fitting in it's not
for me just know that that's a good
feeling
that's the right feeling it's not right
to be like oh
this is the best time of my life
yeah you should want to leave you should
want to get it over with and get on
to the next best thing yeah don't peek
in high school
don't peak in high school and i think
that's a good place for us to end it ron
thank you so much
for coming on the pod it was awesome to
talk to you it's a pleasure
and for everybody else this has been the
roast of your teenage self podcast
you